[Music]
good phones are getting cheap
and cheap phones are getting good so
mkbhd here and i've said that quote
many times over the years over the past
you know thousand videos or so
but i guess now with like the highest
end phones ranging anywhere from
1500 to 2000 bucks feels a lot more like
the
second half is more true than the first
half so this is a little bit of a
different video
not because it's on some crazy piece of
tech it's still on a phone
but as you know i do a lot of videos and
looking at the
highest end bleeding edge best of the
best phones and a lot of the mid-range
where there's a lot of competition
but the benefit is as those get better
and better
well the baseline also gets better and
better
so this video i'm going to be taking a
look at how much smartphone you can get
for that baseline so infinix wanted to
sponsor this video and put their device
in this showcase
so they're coming out with a phone
called the infinix note 8
for 200 flat
in 2020 so this full-blown smartphone
like this
for 200 even like i remember when 200
bucks and below was reserved for
either dumb phones or flip phones or
just extremely old phones that they're
like trying desperately to sell but
we'll probably never see another
software update again and even today 200
bucks is
wireless headphones you know some
bluetooth speakers basically but now
there's clearly full-fledged 200
smartphones like this in 2020
and so my question is how good are they
really how good is this new baseline
because obviously you're not expecting
you know high-end flagship internals or
specs or bells and whistles or anything
but like
how good is this new baseline because
we've come a long way so first of all
let's just start with what comes in the
box
also by the way yes i do have a bunch of
these extra ones over here
stay tuned till the end i'll detail a
little giveaway i'm doing with some of
these on twitter so make sure you're
following over there
but the box here as you can see is
pretty simple giving you the name
and some specs and then when you get
inside the phone is up at the top
and it is a big phone but we'll get to
that in a second
then also included in this sleeve
underneath here is the sim card ejector
tool
a screen protector and then an included
clear plastic case which again you know
in a world where most people do
put a case on their phone it is a pretty
nice thing to see you get that
for free at this baseline then
underneath that is
probably the best part actually because
you can't take this stuff for granted
you also get an 18 watt fast charging
brick a usbc cable
and a pair of wired earbuds so to get
them
and the fast charger in a world where
some don't even have a charger
is pretty good okay so then the phone
itself
i feel like what helps you actually
appreciate what you're getting or how
much you're getting here
is just how much attention they put into
having it
resemble the higher end phones
like i guess at the highest level
they're all kind of
trying to look like the same highest end
phones we've seen that with the notch
and with adding extra cameras and stuff
like that
and at that high level it is kind of
nitpicky
competition stuff but at this level
it's actually really appreciated like
look at this screen a 200
phone used to have small screen big
bezels
i mean they obviously used to not look
that great this phone has
a gigantic display it's a 6.95
inch lcd display so there's tons of room
here
now it is a 1640 by 720 resolution so
clearly not the sharpest thing in the
world but
just as far as typical use you know
scrolling through social media
looking at photos watching videos
especially that's what it's good at
this is fine and there's also a stereo
speaker pair one with the top earpiece
and one at the bottom so you're not
going to easily block the whole thing
with just one finger
and it gets decently loud so the media
experience on this phone already
is actually i'd say pretty impressive
for 200 bucks i'm not going to nitpick
about viewing angles and refresh rate
obviously for this price
but it's worth noting infinix actually
makes another phone here called the zero
eight
which for 250 bucks has a 1080p
90hz display so there you go but let's
get over here to the back of the phone
the back of the note8 here is this like
interesting pattern of glossy blue
pyramid shapes it's pretty neat i guess
plastic material
of course but hey you can drop that case
on it that you got for free with the
phone if you want to
and then at the bottom here you may
notice it is usb type-c
which again you actually shouldn't take
for granted there's like a whole world
of gadgets that are still catching up
on that front and also a headphone jack
which actually still feels more
necessary
in this world of budget phones where not
everybody is also trying to shell out
100 more dollars on wireless headphones
do i know my favorite thing though that
they mimicked from high-end phones
is the gigantic battery a lot of phones
coming out now have huge batteries
this one has a 5 200 milliamp hour
battery
that's pretty sweet they've branded it
they call it power marathon tech
i just call it a huge battery honestly
and we know
when you combine huge battery with a
720p display
and a chip that doesn't take a ton of
power there's a helio g80 processor
in this phone you're looking at a two
day phone for a lot of people
who get this phone and they're still
fast charging if you need it then the
software experience
takes inspiration from a couple
different places i can tell though it is
obviously still skinned there's no
getting around
that with what they're calling xos on
top of android 10
and there are some ads in the os as
we've seen in some other affordable
phones
and there are some pre-loaded apps as
well but hey that's the beauty of
android is if you want to drop another
launcher on
here or uninstall basically any of these
apps
you can easily do so and performance is
good enough through animations and
scrolling as you can see
this is what 60hz is going to feel like
and you're also getting 128 gigs of
storage
and 6 gigs of ram so enough to run some
games on that
huge nearly 7 inch display and feel
totally fine with it
and there's a couple interesting
features built into the software too
like i found
there's this multitasking pop-up that
comes up when you swipe in from the side
and hold
and that will give you some shortcuts to
quickly get into your top five favorite
apps you can customize
or start a screen recording or take a
screenshot quickly
so that's actually something pretty
unique i don't think i've seen on any
other phones at all now for cameras
this this might be the area where it
it's it's most trying to
look like the most expensive phones
and it i think it does that's why you've
got this this bar back here
total six cameras on this phone four on
the back
two on the front so the four back
cameras are the 64 megapixel
main camera then macro camera a dev
sensor and what they call the ai lens so
yeah mostly what you're going to be
working with here are the main camera
and maybe occasionally the macro and the
photos you get
out of this 200 phone i'd say are
passable
now of course as soon as you get into
difficult lighting you know where you
wouldn't even think of bringing
some phones from the past this is where
this one will start to suffer
mainly in dynamic range and noise but
again i don't think anybody buying this
phone will mind that one bit
and the fact that this camera is so nice
and snappy actually pretty responsive in
the first place
is a nice bonus and then the selfie
camera up here at the front
in your dual infinity o cutout is joined
by a depth sensor as well for improved
portrait mode
again just makes it look more like the
high-end phones of this past year but
you know the photos are passable for 200
bucks
and even a little portrait mode action
will work if you're into that so overall
i'm actually i would say impressed i
think i've gotten in such a good rhythm
of
looking at all these different high-end
bleeding edge phones
and we also know what to expect in that
sort of hardware but on another level
i think it's harder to make a good phone
at this price
like a lot of good decisions have to go
into
making a good phone for 200 bucks
and it's happening it's happening in
2020. this phone
costs less than a pair of airpods pro
that's pretty crazy so thanks again to
infinix for sponsoring this video they
sent over
a bunch here i've got about five
note eights to give away on twitter so
make sure you follow on twitter i'll
link it below like button
and uh stay tuned for the tweet where
i'll give some of these away but
i want to know what you guys think is
the most impressive piece of a good
phone for 200 bucks in 2020. what was
the piece that impressed you the most
let me know in the comments below
either way thanks for watching catch you
guys in the next one
peace